the fun matchup to watch with Mitchell
on Tatum and on Tatum floating along the
baseline with a beautiful touch here's
O'Neill with a spot-up 3-pointer that
won't fall Utah really struggling from
the floor Tatum on the other end
sneaking down court and it's 9 for
Celtics an eagle way off on the three
Utah two of 1205 three point land Tatum
drives all the smooth was that down
early for Jason Tate him his third
bucket already look at him move in and
out dribble right there he's so long and
then coach Stevens talked about him
being able to finish at a high level
right now much better than they did
earlier in the season here's Mitchell
went to the shoots gets all the way to
the rim and lays it in
Austin right now second of these two
games behind Toronto the Joel penetrates
Wow I like a spin on that
it'll go to the line nice over the top
right there
I stopped picking up the ball and just
putting that thing right on the glass
very very softly there's a lot of teams
that made a mistake on Donovan Mitchell
as well no question
tain him with the step through and the
finish with the offhand 9 points that
he's only taken one three so far in the
game and missed 147 this year with the
dribble shaking cancer and getting the
basket and look we talked about him he's
feeling good
Tatum's working against the a pull-off
jumper is good Tatum with 11 here in the
first half 5 of 7 shooting I mean this
kid is we are witnessing a kid's happen
to his potential of not all-star but
superstar level 7 of Mitchell's 9 coming
here in the first three minutes of the
quarter Tatum goes behind the back
step-back three got it 1414 in his first
three pointer you look at him and
isolation situation just sizing up the
defenders sidestep step off three points
the battle not tonight
I mean one of them could've definitely
wanted a different jazz player back on
the floor over three from the field
[ __ ] Donna [ __ ] finds a cutting
Mitchell Mitchell sparked his basketball
team looking at moving without the
basketball and that was a nice business
decision he'd go bear has had a longer
streak right now ten of a rogue who go
there that's the other thing it's just
amazing
Donovan Mitchell continues to shine here
on the quarter he's got 16 points now
Edward 1 for 6
Mitchell against Tatum school
I mean this is just a special special
young talent right here two big time
players going at it right now in Salt
Lake City
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's feeling it right now
Donna damn it roll on fire it doesn't
matter right now winds blew really good
players have it going it's not much you
can do hate him just as good on the
other end Tatum was 16 on 7 of 10 from
the floor on the outside of the playoff
picture in that race for eighth in the
West here stayed up a 3-ball got it his
second triple and Boston back in front
[Applause]